i'm using yeah i'm doing my best
here he started to share
it threatened to share i didn't realize
that okay
oh good is it working yeah we hear you
we see you we can see your mouse pointer
even
i think we're all good fantastic all
right so
uh salil is going to wrap up the
workshop with a talk
on models of computation reduction
between algorithms
please go ahead sleil excellent okay
thank you so much
to the organizers for inviting me to
give this talk and thanks to everyone
who
has made it to the final talk on the
final day of this workshop
it's been a fantastic time because i
know that
many of you are probably tired as i am
i tried to make this this talk a little
bit more entertaining
and uh easy going so
um you may be disappointed to not see
any proofs um but
but you know feel free to contact me
afterwards if you want
uh to see more technical details okay so
let's get started so
um the title of the talk deviates a
little bit from the title as advertised
on the workshop
page um but we're going to be talking
about models of computation
and specifically reductions between
algorithms
okay so in high dimensional statistics
many times we find ourselves in the
following setting we have
uh data and uh
you know this data is is uh maybe takes
the forms of uh
m samples and uh and dimensions so and
we think of m and n
as going to infinity and then what we
want to do is we want to feed this data
into an algorithm
and then we want to spit out conclusions
right so you can think of problems like
estimation inference or for the
majority of this talk the focus is going
to be on hypothesis testing
and i'll say more precisely what i mean
by that later and
because we are optimists we want to
tolerate data that is noisy
and still have our algorithms be fast
but sadly for us it seems that
oftentimes
noise your data requires slower
algorithms okay
and now the next part of this talk is
going to be like the next couple of
slides will be
very familiar you've seen the sequence
of slides in many of the talks that
preceded this talk at this workshop
so feel free to you know sing along with
a chorus at home uh if you feel
moved to do so um but what we see are
these computation
uh what we see are these computational
phase transitions right so
um for any given problem we have a
parameter that we call the signal to
noise ratio
and maybe measured in terms of a number
of samples
uh as it will often be in this talk
or maybe it's some other you know like
uh
quantization of the quality of the data
um and what we have is we have several
phases in the signal to noise ratio so
when the signal noise ratio is really
low
the problem is impossible to solve
and then we see another phase uh so by
impossible i mean information
theoretically impossible like
uh you cannot you know distinguish your
data from random noise
and then we see another phase where uh
we conjecture that the problem is hard
okay so what this means is that even
though information theoretically there
are good estimators we don't know
any estimators that run in polynomial
time
and then finally there's a regime where
where the problem becomes easy meaning
we have polynomial time algorithms to
solve this
and we've seen this occurring over and
over again in this workshop essentially
every talk has been
exactly about this topic um so i've
listed many problems here but i'm going
to use
planted clique as kind of the model
problem for the rest of this talk
okay so planet clique uh probably we
could all
uh define this but i'm going to to do it
anyway just because this song is being
recorded
so um for those of you watching at home
uh in planet clique we have the
following problem we have the null
distribution which is just an
eredish rainy graph gn half so this
means i have a graph
and every edge is included independently
with probability half
okay and in the alternate distribution i
have
again g and half but in this case i take
a set of k vertices
and i plan to click on them so this is
okay click
and then for the remaining edges they're
all
included again with probability half
okay and our goal is to hypothesis test
between these two distributions
so what this means is that i get a graph
and i want to decide if it more likely
came from the
to training distribution or from my
alternate distribution with a planted
cake leak
so here the signal to noise ratio is
typically measured by
k the size of the planted clique okay
and the phase diagram looks like this
if the click has size smaller than 2 log
n
it's impossible to hypothesis test
then if the click has size between 2 log
n and root n
the problem is conjectured to be hard
okay and then above reading there's a
there's an algorithm so the problem
becomes easy
all right so so that's a story with
planet clique but what we want is we we
don't want
just conjecture okay so so why do i say
conjectured heart i guess i guess it's
because we have evidence so the point is
that we want evidence for hardness
uh in the conjectured heart regime so
what is our evidence
oops so okay
if we turn to classical complexity
theory one thing we might be tempted to
do is to
have uh reductions right so in classical
complexity theory
we have the space of all problems and
then what we do is we
say that one problem is just as hard as
another problem if there's a polynomial
time algorithm that reduces from
one problem to the next um
and we we like to arrange problems in
these equivalence classes
such as the equivalence class of np
complete problems by saying that they're
all
you know pairwise uh polynomial time
reducible to each other
but if you imagine trying to do to do
this for for statistical problems i mean
this is exactly the topic of guys talk
just before mine the the situation gets
much trickier and the
reductions get much more complicated and
then let me just
re-pose one of the challenges that was
mentioned in the previous talk
imagine a reduction from uh
planted clique on a g
n half to point to click on g
and one quarter okay so so
in terms of how difficult we believe
these problems would be we believe them
to be essentially equivalent
but it's difficult to imagine a
polynomial time reduction from one
problem to the other
another thing that you could ask is can
you get a reduction from planted clique
to
ksat
okay so so these are like the average
case analogs of
max clique and let's say three sets
it's very easy to reduce between these
problems in polynomial time
um in the worst case it's one of the
things like the first reductions that
you you know teach to an undergraduate
um in a you know introductory complexity
class
but for the average case version it
seems like a
challenge that's beyond the current the
techniques okay so
so most of our evidence uh at least
in the present day comes from a
different approach
and that approach is ruling out
restricted models of computation
so what do i mean when i say restricted
models of computation
here i basically mean classes of
algorithms right so um we've seen
many i mean there are many classes of
algorithms but there are kind of a
couple of uh
you know favorite uh
problem classic or uh models of
computation that that are used
throughout
uh you know statistics for statistical
problems
so just just to point out the ones
featured in this workshop which are also
kind of the main popular ones we have
things like spectral algorithms
so here you can think of simple things
like computing the covariance matrix or
maybe
things based on the non-backtracking
spectrum
um we have things like a convex program
so this can
this can include you know sophisticated
uh
convex programs such as sum of squares
or kind of a
less powerful program such as linear
programs but but i want you to basically
think of sum of squares throughout this
uh talk
um we have statistical query algorithms
which i'll tell you
more about later uh low degree
polynomials which was the focus of
alex's talk um gradient methods here you
can think of things like
longitudinal dynamics
mcmc methods here you can think of
things like the global dynamics
and we saw talks about that this morning
from
superbrada and uh elias
and uh message passing and here i mean
things like approximate message passing
or belief propagation
or even the kikuchi message passing
method
right so so when we want to show that a
problem is hard when we want to get
evidence for hardness
basically what we do is we show that all
our models are stuck
okay so uh for example for the problem
of planted clique
in uh 92 and then germ proved that you
need the
clique to have size at least root n in
order for markov chains to work and then
this was
refined a little bit more recently by
david and elias and then uh same for
message passing
i just wanted montenaria showed that you
need the plain clique to have size at
least root n
for spectral algorithms uh the kind of
uh known spectral logarithms are stuck
at root n
for statistical query algorithms because
of some issues with model specification
this isn't this there is a reduction
from planet clique to
statistical queries that show that you
need uh at least okay to be
strong but um it's for a kind of
bipartite version of the atlantic league
so
this this will i will circle back to
this towards the end of the talk
but there's some kind of evidence that
you need the cliques to have size at
least you're done
for convex programs and for low degree
polynomials simultaneously
we also need k to be larger than root n
as shown by barack at all um
in their paper which which shows that
you need you know
uh quasi polynomial size convex programs
to solve planet clique
okay so so this is a this is it we we
have a problem
we want to show that it's hard in the
hard regime we eliminate one of each of
our models of computation one by one and
then we say okay well
uh looks like if we're going to beat the
current signal noise ratio at which we
can solve this problem we're going to
need a
drastically new algorithmic technique
okay all right so that's that's the
state of the art basically
um you know for each problem what we do
is we eliminate all of our models of
computation
and uh this is uh this is sort of an
unfortunate uh
you know situation that we find
ourselves in i think like
you know imagine that a new important
problem pops up today
vaccine verification
whatever that means okay what we have to
do is we have to go problem by problem
and say
markov chains can't solve it message
passing can't solve it spectrologically
can't solve it
you know and and what we what we would
kind of expect is like okay well i
eliminated one
algorithmic method and like all these
things are kind of the same
uh like in their performance so you know
if i if i did one like i shouldn't have
to do
all of them uh right like
if we think of this as a bipartite graph
with uh like
n models of computation and m problems
like this requires us to write o
of m n papers
but uh but maybe there's a better way
right so
what if we could instead
are you trying to minimize the number of
papers
yeah i am
i mean okay you know you can do whatever
you want but um okay so so yeah so
so what if there was a different way
right what if we could show
that these algorithms have roughly
equivalent performance for all these
problems for a reason
what if we could show that let's say a
low degree
polynomials and spectral algorithms have
equivalent performance
for many if not all of the statistical
problems that we care about
um and similarly you know we could we
could relate spectral algorithms to
markov chains to message passing and
backwards right
and now if we do this all we do is we
start with
with our favorite problem let's say
planet clique and we only have to
rule out one of the methods and then
once we rule out one of the methods
we get to rule out all of them
right so so now yeah for each problem
you can pick you know your
your favorite uh method of finding lower
bounds
you know something like this right and
now we only have to write
order of n plus m papers
so to recycle a joke that i use in a
previous iteration of this talk
um one time my my uh
dear friend sam hopkins explained to me
the business model
of iceland air okay so so what does
iceland air
have that no one else has they have an
island in the middle of the atlantic
ocean
right and so if there's n cities on
the atlantic and m cities in europe they
only need to order
n plus m planes right just to fly back
and forth to
the island uh in the middle of the
atlantic whereas
united has to buy n times m planes right
one for every pair of cities uh on the
atlantic versus pacific
or i mean sorry the two sides of the
atlantic and so so what we really want
to do is we want to be
we don't want to be like united right we
want to be like iceland air we want to
be efficient
and uh you know save our our work uh for
for uh you know the most interesting
uh problems that we we can think of
right so
okay so that's the dream ryan made a
face
i really wanted the laugh track queued
up but somehow that punchline didn't
quite land
there's so many good ones before like i
missed the opportunity
i thought it was something i said no no
you should just bring your own like air
horn or something
sorry go on all right so so anyway so
this is the dream
okay and and uh and it is
it is a very ambitious dream and i i
don't know if we're going to be
able to realize it quite like this but
there are
some modest steps towards uh realizing
this dream okay that have been happening
uh recently so
um i want to mention just a couple of
of works because i um consider these to
be the ones that capture kind of the
largest classes of
uh statistical problems um
so i'll talk today about a work that
relates
uh convex programs to some subclass of
spectral algorithms
and uh this is a joint work with
um sam hopkins pravesh khathari
um aaron patechan procedural govendra
and david stoyer
from fox17 okay so we'll see
this result a little later i also want
to mention a work that
reduces some subset of convex programs
so some restricted class of conduct
programs to statistical query algorithms
so this is by uh feldman guzman and
impala
also from 2017. i won't have time to to
talk about uh this today
um and then uh after spending a little
bit of time
on the um spectral algorithm and convex
program equivalence i'll talk about
statistical query algorithms and low
degree
polynomial equivalents and this is based
on some really recent
work with uh matt bresler oh sorry matt
brennan guy brazler
uh sam hopkins jerry lee uh
now available hot off the presses on
archive
okay and then there's a there's a
somewhat um different approach as well
but i consider that to be part of this
this general umbrella of getting
reductions between algorithm which is
to understand what kind of hard
structures um
mean that these algorithms fail so we
saw a couple of talks this morning about
the overlapped gap property
um you know doing things like saying if
there is an overlap gap
property then low degree polynomials
fail
um or message passing fails or markov
chain fails
um i think this is uh it's not exactly
the same but i think this is also
you know part of the same general idea
of having reductions between algorithms
or at least
understanding you know what structures
are there that make
all these algorithms fail uh commonly so
i guess i should at least
cite um gamarnica juggernauts
and one for these overlap gap reductions
okay so so the plan for the rest of the
talk today is going to be to
see at least what this result which
reduces
sos to spectral algorithms is and
vice versa and then also to see the
statistical query versus the degree
polynomial reduction
and i'm going to spend the majority of
my time setting this up
here i'm only going to give you a little
taste
of what's going on um but let me try to
encourage you
to view the technical portion of this
talk
with uh soft eyes so to explain what i
mean
i'm going to make a big risk here and
i'm going to try to
play a video for you all
so let's see
okay
all right let me know if it's working
it's probably not working it's not
working we're frozen
who is it bonking keema yeah let me try
again
oh there we go no sound though oh yeah
sounds not on
all right sorry sorry
holy there's some way to play youtube
via
oh it's good go back to the beginning
now yeah yeah sorry
yeah i knew this would happen but it's
worth it for the
okay let's go
rubble gloves
like i'm supposed to cry so you can see
the whole thing you got hard eyes
you standing at the same tree what's in
the forest
[Music]
soft eyes grasshopper
all right so uh hopefully that was at
least mildly successful and you
got some of the point of that video but
the point is that you you should
you should look at these results with
with kind of soft eyes and try to see
you know they're explaining power and
and see kind of like the the general uh
picture and then if you feel so inspired
you can go later and check the papers on
archive and or
uh message me or one of my co-authors
okay so that's enough philosophy for now
so let me tell you a little story about
uh sum of squares and spectral
algorithms
this is just to kind of set the stage
for what's going on
so uh back in the
in the you know mid 2000 aughts or the
early 2010s
uh this the sum of squares algorithm was
uh
just becoming popular and
for worst case problems there was this
feeling that sum of squares
is really much more powerful than
spectral algorithms or or many of the
other
algorithms that came before it so for
example for problems like three coloring
in worst case graphs
uh there were advances using the sum of
squares
uh convicts programs that just seemed
like impossible to match with with uh
spectral algorithms right i mean it
wouldn't even be
it wouldn't even make sense to try to
match them with a spectral algorithm
um but but somehow there weren't that
many algorithms that were coming out
where sum of squares was really
improving the state of the art results
in in polynomial time
and then circa 2012 and uh uh
the couple of years afterwards a couple
of works came out
which which showed that some of squares
was making
big gains for for several statistical
problems so really pushing the signal to
noise ratios
at which problems were able to be solved
and i just put a smattering of examples
up here um this isn't supposed to be
a comprehensive list there wasn't that
much room on the slide
um but for things like tensor
decomposition or dictionary learning or
tensor pca
uh some of the scores were really
introducing algorithms that were
substantially beating
the previously considered algorithms
but then in around 2016
it turned out that many of these uh
sum of squares algorithms were actually
able to be matched with
spectral algorithms um so you have a
spectral algorithm which isn't doing any
optimization over
sort of a convex uh body uh that is
nonetheless
approximately matching the performance
of sum of squares i don't i don't mean
exactly i mean in some of the cases
there were legs and then here also there
were a couple of papers that i
maybe could have written and didn't um
but you know maybe it's worth mentioning
that
these spectral algorithms weren't sort
of your vanilla sort of
spectral algorithms right so like
traditionally
uh what does a spectral algorithm look
like you know you have a bunch of
samples
uh in let's say n dimensions
and then you make their covariance
matrix right
and then you evaluate its top eigenvalue
or top eigenvector
or maybe your input is like a tensor
like a you know n by n by n tensor
and uh you flatten it out into a
rectangle like an x squared by a
rectangle and then you
take the you know top eigenvector
top eigenvalue of that okay but these
new algorithms were a little bit fancier
so what they would do is they would take
the data
and then they would make a matrix whose
entries were like
higher degree polynomials of that data
right so let's say like
if we look at this paper for the tensor
decomposition problem the entries were
degree
seven polynomials
of the input tensor
okay so so so the spectral algorithms
were a little bit different than the
ones that have been seen before and they
were
inspired sort of by the analysis of sum
of squares
um and you know the question was
you know is this is this phenomenon uh
an isolated incident or
is there like a deeper explanation for
why this is happening that the big
powerful sum of squares relaxations are
being matched
uh by you know these these supposedly
weaker spectral algorithms
okay so it turns out that uh in
in this work with uh hopkins qatari
potato and ricotta
and store we were able to give a theorem
which explains that for a large class of
statistical problems the success of
degree d
sum of squares implies that there's a
algorithm running in time roughly into
the order d
which does just as well okay so so in
order to
explain this theorem let me kind of
introduce the three main characters
of the theorem which are degree d sum of
squares degree d spectral algorithms and
robust uh noise robust blinded problems
also feel free to interrupt me for
questions at any time i should say
okay so so degree design of squares so
we've seen this uh
in in previous talks at the workshop but
let me just refresh you
briefly on what this means so we
say we have some polynomial optimization
problem
uh you know let's try it let's say where
we let's call it
a and it takes as input some some g g is
supposed to evoke a graph adjacency
matrix here for example
and it's trying to maximize some
polynomial in g
and some variables x subject to some
polynomial constraints
okay so so we start with some polynomial
optimization problem i want you to think
for example of max clique
which uh which if you think about it for
a couple of minutes you can see that
you know you can formulate as a
polynomial optimization problem in the
graph description and then
the sum of squares uh relaxation at
degree d
is kind of the best semi-definite
programming
relaxation for a
of size uh
and to the order d
okay so so here i've i'm leaving things
vague remember the soft eyes
um but let me just say that that for a
large class of uh
problems we know that this best is
actually
literally the best um so for example you
can look at the work of leo ricovendra
and storier
from 2015. okay so that's what i mean by
degree sum of squares
now let me introduce a class of spectral
algorithms so a restricted class of
spectral algorithms
which i'll call degree capital d
spectral algorithms
so here uh what i have is i have a
map a matrix value graph from
inputs in n dimensions let's say to
matrices that are n to the d by
n to the d so if i take f
of g
my output is a matrix
and then every entry of this matrix has
is a degree
uh d polynomial
in the input okay so if my input is an
adjacency matrix
uh it's it's some function of the most d
edges
in the graph and what my spectral
algorithm is allowed to do is it's only
allowed to evaluate the maximum
eigenvalue
of f and threshold it so it's
so my algorithm is basically the
indicator function that uh the
maximum eigenvalue of f
is bigger than some threshold theta
okay so that's the restricted class of
spectral algorithms that we're working
with
okay and now uh what algorithms are or
what what problems are we trying to
solve we're trying to solve noise
reverse planting problems so in noise
robust planted problems i have some
null distribution uh over rn
so here i only get samples g and i have
some planted distribution
over uh r and uh
m cross r a little n so i get samples of
form g x
and the idea is that i'm going to set it
up so that
in expectation over
samples from the alternate distribution
the value
of some polynomial optimization problem
such of a g
is much larger than the expected value
under the null distribution
okay so so if we think about uh the max
click example
here you would have let's say the null
distribution be a detraining graph
and the alternate distribution be a
joint distribution over pairs of graphs
and
indicators for where the planted clique
is right and and
this this planted solution witnesses the
fact that the value of this polynomial
optimization problem is much larger
uh in the alternate case than in all
case
so so that's that's a general setup what
do i mean by noise robustness i mean
that this continues to be true
so this should still be true
if i apply
noise from uh
d0 to d1
right so what this means is uh for
planet clique for example you can
imagine
that you take your graph of the planet
clique and then you choose some random
subset of the vertices that you're going
to
keep as is and then every edge that is
outside of that subset of vertices you
re-randomize it so when you do that
you're still going to have a large plane
to click inside right so you can apply
noise
and the optimization problem is still
robust there's still a much larger
maximum clique in the alternate
distribution versus the null
distribution
okay so supposing that uh so so now that
i think
this introduces all the characters and
now we can say the theorem
so okay so what we proved is the
following
so if the degree d sum of squares uh
program or relaxation for this
optimization problem
distinguishes our null distribution from
a noisy version
of the alternate distribution
then there's also a degree order epsilon
d spectral algorithm
which distinguishes the original
distribution so if sum of squares
solves a slightly harder problem the
noisy problem
then a spectral algorithm will solve the
original problem
um okay so so roughly that's the
that's the statement
uh let me just say that the proof is
non-constructive
so that that makes this feel a little
bit unsatisfying i mean it's not really
like a reduction between algorithms per
se like it's not like i produce for you
the the spectral algorithm for you to
run uh by hand and it's it's
furthermore like not even guaranteed the
same spectral algorithm will work for
every value of n that you choose
um but still you know we are explaining
with a theorem this uh seeming
equivalence that we
observed in uh in practice so to speak
um
and and also i just want to say that
this this setup is sort of rich enough
to capture
several of the problems that we care
about so many problems that we care
about so
for example plants and clique uh as i've
been alluding to
uh also tensor pca
community dissection
etc
all right maybe it's good to pause for
questions
no questions you have a question um
is it possible that this framework could
be used to prove
sos lower bounds like maybe you give a
family of uh matrices and then
if you can bound the spectral norm of
every matrix in this family by
some number yeah like like in principle
it sounds like such thing as possible
but yeah this is a this is an excellent
question and i'm going to answer it but
um i hope i worry that my answer may
only be comprehensible to experts so if
i lose you during the answer to this
question don't be worried
um the issue here is that we're not
looking at the maximum
uh the maximum absolute value of an
eigenvalue we're looking at the maximum
positive magnitude eigenvalue so so if
you were looking at the maximum
absolute value eigenvalue then uh
then you could probably you know i mean
i think it would be pretty immediate to
get
lower bounds but but because the class
is defined in this way
i actually don't know how to show lower
bounds against this class of spectral
algorithms um
so so it's a little yeah it's a little
tricky but it's possible that it would
be a way
to prove uh sos lower bounds
cool cool okay can i ask
also um so though like you said this
uh particular strategy is not
constructive the original kind of
phenomenon that motivated this
was a constructive relationship right
between sos
at least proof techniques and uh
and these uh these polynomial like
spectral methods
right so do you think that there's some
hope to kind of analyze
the situation differently such that this
does become constructive
i think that would be fantastic um i
myself don't know
how to do it um
yeah uh but but i think it would be
great
if you could have a black box result of
that form
can i ask a really naive question so
what about spectral algorithms where i
limit
the size of the matrix maybe even to the
original size of the instance
but that but i have arbitrary
element-wise
an arbitrary function which is applied
to the elements yeah yeah so
so that's a great question what you can
do there actually
it's uh if you're allowed to apply an
arbitrary function what you can do is
you can
say evaluate the likelihood ratio in
just one entry right so you can have a
one by one matrix where you're doing
like the optimal hypothesis test
um and then like you that
i mean that is a that is a very powerful
class of spectral algorithms i'm saying
um so
i mean do we have lower do we know that
that type of algorithm
doesn't work for you know gaussian
sub matrix localization for instance in
a certain range
i think that that type of algorithm
should probably work anywhere i mean you
can just
evaluate the information theoretic like
right if there's an information
theoretic test that works information
theoretically
you just take it and then put that as
your function in the input of the matrix
so
but no i i i but i i mean a much more
restricted thing i i i take the
i take the entries of the instance and i
apply the same function to each
other and then just look at the spectrum
of the resulting matrix
um and the function has to be
the the function of only
that entry or it can be a function of
all of the entries
just that one entry i mean it's a very
limited class
but but i'm not limiting the degree of
the poem i'm not saying it's a
polynomial degree d
it could be some crazy transcendental
thing
i don't i don't know i would have to
think about it but my guess is that
would
not be a very powerful class
uh okay great anyway um so thank you for
the questions
oh ryan are you you're in meetings there
was one question from chris jones i
don't know if it got answered properly
he's
on the call i think it was answered
correctly thank you that was
sidon's question okay great thanks chris
go ahead
cool okay so now um we move on from
from this part uh and now i just wanted
to to
kind of say a little bit more philosophy
of how we could possibly make
make these uh dreams come true and
i think that there's a lot of promise to
considering low degree polynomials
so i i really love uh degree polynomials
and let me tell you a couple of the the
reasons why okay so
one reason is that they capture many
algorithms
so alex went into this uh in great
detail
yesterday and it was an excellent talk
so i'm just
going to you know very vaguely say that
we know that
many uh spectral methods can be reduced
to low degree polynomials
uh same with some subclass of message
passing algorithms
uh and there's even some sense in which
uh convex programs may be
reducible to low-degree polynomials so
this is following the work of
barack at all um
for uh planted clique
so there is a there is some hope that
one could
use low-degree polynomials as the kind
of uh
like uh iceland of uh of our
um you know like uh
airline right we could we could just try
to show that all of these
methods are equivalent to low degree
polynomials um it's possible that it
would work
another reason why i like them is
because they sort of have explaining
power
so in the sense that the failure of low
degree polynomials
it's almost a structural property in
itself because
it's a statement about the low degree
moments
of the distributions that you're
considering the non-alternate
distributions being
uh too close to tell apart so
so it's it's not something like uh it's
not a geometric property but at least
it's an algebraic property that
um is more concrete and maybe easy to
check
than uh saying that you know sum of
squares programs
can't distinguish these two things um
and then
finally i think that they're pretty easy
to work with in many cases
so you know if you if you come and you
tell me
um you know here is the vaccine
verification problem
prove to me a sum of squares lower bound
for this problem i will say
uh like it's gonna take me a while
okay but but if if i just have to prove
that the low degree moments are
not easy to distinguish it might be a
calculation that only takes
you know an hour or an afternoon um
that's not always the case but
but typically uh they're more
approachable to work with
so i think that you know if we're
focusing
on kind of connecting this graph um
low degree polynomials are a good bet to
be to be working with
um okay so so then for the rest of the
so that was my little pitch for literary
polynomials
uh for the rest of the talk i'll be
talking about the
um correspondence between statistical
query algorithms and low degree
polynomials
and i see that i don't have a ton of
time left so it might be
a little bit uh hasty but hopefully
that's all right
all right so this is a this is a new
paper that
we just wrote with matt guy sam and
jerry
um and i'm i'm very excited about this
work and i was
very happy to be working with this
fantastic team we had a
we had a lot of fun uh this summer um
so yeah and what we do is we basically
show that statistical query algorithms
and low degree tests are
almost equivalent okay the operative
word being
uh almost but but it's not
i mean the almost is is precise enough
that we're able to get a lot of
uh lower bounds for free so for example
we're able to get
uh tensor pca lower bounds that already
exist for low degree polynomials to
imply
uh statistical query lower bounds for
tensor pca same thing
for a random threesat
and uh sparse pca
and for a new version of planted clique
which is not bipartite
and also we're able to get existing
statistical query lower bounds for
gaussian mixtures and robust mean
estimation
to imply a low degree polynomial lower
bounds
so uh so here like if you look at the
paper you can
look with hard eyes and really kind of
like track how
well we are getting these equivalences
down
um okay so so uh without further ado
i'll tell you about the the setup for
this
uh theorem and and try to at least get
to the theorem statement
all right so the setting that we're
interested in is hypothesis testing as
before
we're going to have a null distribution
over
rn so here you can think of for example
planted clique the null distribution
would just be
iridesce random graphs and we'll have an
alternate distribution
which is actually going to be a
collection of distributions dv
with a prior over the v's so this is a
little bit confusing to digest it first
but
think of v for example as subsets
of uh n with size uh
k and then uh you can think of the
prior mu is uh uniform over these
and then each dv is going to be uh g
n p plus a cake leaf on v
all right uh the reason why we're doing
this this way will hopefully become
clear on the very next slide
but we're doing a set up this way and
what we're going to do is we're going to
measure uh what we're going to see is
we're going to see
m samples either from
the null distribution or from some
specific
dv sampled from you right so the point
is that all m of my samples come from
the same
uh distribution and alternate
distribution class
and the reason why this is happening is
because of the way that statistical
query algorithms are
defined um so yeah again on the very
next slide the place will be clear
and our goal is going to be to design an
algorithm which minimizes the
probability of
saying that we have the alternate
distribution under the null uh
class plus the probability that we um
are saying that we have the null
distribution under the alternate class
so this is just minimizing type 1 plus
type 2 error as usual
okay so what are statistical queries so
statistical queries is a uh oracle
model for access to a distribution um
that that is as follows so
what you have is you have any bounded
function from
rn that is a single sample to zero one
okay you can take this function you can
feed it to
an oracle which is a statistical query
oracle in this talk we're going to focus
on v stacks
there's a number of different oracles
with different guarantees but sort of
v-stat is a
maybe like the the state of the art and
uh what v-stat will do
is oh and it takes it takes some
parameter m and what v-stat will do is
it will tell you
the expectation of this function under
the distribution in question
on a single sample up to an error
right so so this area is an adversarial
error
but it's supposed to mimic the
concentration
from bernstein inequality
on m samples
okay so so v stat m basically
corresponds to
m samples roughly
and an sq algorithm is an algorithm
which only interacts
with the data via sq queries so it's
it's allowed to ask queue
queries to vstat and then it processes
these queries however
it likes okay so our proxy for run
running time is going to be entirely uh
the number of queries
so we've replaced running time with
query complexity
and our proxy for the signal to noise
ratio is
m this parameter which roughly
corresponds to the number of samples
okay so uh what's what's an example of a
commonly used statistical query
algorithm
well one such example is the method of
moments
right so in the method of moments what
you do is uh you
have a bunch of data and what you want
to do is you want to compute moments of
it so
like a fee of x would be
expectation of x to the s let's say
just a question um
can you scare me sorry yeah i can hear
you yeah this is a question because i'm
not like super familiar with the
sq model like this is not the bounded
function right the moment
is it uh yeah sorry you would you would
uh so it depends it depends where you
are like maybe like if you're in a
discreet district like over the hyperkey
the moments are bounded um but but you
could
often times you can deal with these
things by applying some threshold
like uh okay so that's your perspective
okay
okay thanks yeah excellent
great questions yeah any other questions
all right uh i'll move on but if anyone
is confused feel free to interrupt at
any time
okay our second model is going to be low
degree tests so we've heard a little bit
about these in the workshops
um but we're going to have is we're
going to have a polynomial
in all m of the samples and the
polynomial
is going to have a bounded degree and
we'll choose some threshold which is
going to be a real number
and our low degree test is just going to
be checking
if the polynomial evaluated on the data
is bigger than some threshold value
theta
right and and we're hoping that the
answer is going to be one in the planned
case and zero in all case
all right now uh let me say something
about uh
what kind of notion of bounded degree
we're going to have because it's going
to be a little bit different than
what alex was discussing yesterday so
we have this notion that we call this
sample wise degree
so we say that polynomial is sample wise
degree dk
if when you look at the
matrix of data so the n by m matrix of
data where each
data point is a column x i uh
it has sample wise degree dk if it uses
in most k
columns so every monomial only touches
in most k
columns or samples
and every monomial uses at most d
entries of a sample
hey can i ask a quick question yeah so
if i'm thinking about planted clique for
instance are these m
independent draws from the distribution
of graphs with planted gleek and do they
have the same planted clique over and
over or
a new uniformly random plant to click in
each in each one
yeah so okay so i'll say more about that
a little bit later but
but yeah already you should start to
feel a little bit uneasy like it doesn't
seem like my favorite problem is going
to be captured by this
hypothesis testing framework but but
i'll bail you out in uh
like uh forest lives maybe maybe only
two slides
um okay anyway so this is going to be my
notion of degree and
it's uh equivalent to the usual notion
of degree up to a quadratic factor right
like a degree
sample-wise degree dk polynomial has a
degree d
k at least over um let's say like the
hypercube
uh yeah so so so okay so now
my uh and the reason that i'm gonna do
so so you can just feel free to think of
it as like degree d times k
for this but for the proofs it's easier
to have this sample wise degree notion
um and okay so what's our proxy for the
running time well it takes time
n to the d times m to the k to evaluate
such polynomials
i think we just don't see either oh okay
just update it i'm sorry okay i just
couldn't see before updates yeah okay
okay uh yeah please let me know if that
stops happening because uh
it would be it would be good to know
okay so so our proxy for the running
time is going to be
the time to evaluate the polynomial
right so that's something like
n to the dm's decay and our proxy for
signal to noise ratio is again going to
be
m the number of samples
okay and we already said uh a couple of
examples of
of uh low degree tests or we saw them
yesterday and alex's talk but um for
example spectral algorithms are often
low degree
so one way to see this
is that if you look at the algorithm
that
takes for example the adjacency matrix
of a graph and evaluates its top
eigenvalue
what you do is you would take the
adjacency matrix which is
which has degree one
in your input you take the
trace of a 12th power of this
and then this is supposed to be
something like the maximum eigenvalue
to the l and now you can apply some
threshold
okay so so it has sample wise i guess
degree uh
l uh one
okay so
okay so what we were hoping for
is to say that uh the two
k query uh vista
uh um algorithms are equivalent to
m sample uh
degree order k
polynomial or tests
right this would this would sort of uh
make the running time
and uh uh like uh
signals noise equivalent roughly between
the two models but there's
there's a problem of model mismatch so
one problem is that
sometimes statistical queries are much
more powerful than low degree tests
because uh the functions that we can ask
to the oracle
can be uh inefficient can be hard
for example you can have your function
be the indicator that g contains a cake
leak
okay so so that that looks really bad
right um
and and uh another issue is that
sometimes
low degree tests can be more powerful
than statistical queries
isn't the reason for this is that
the queries can only see one sample at a
time
at a time uh whereas the polynomials
remember we we have the sample wise
degree dk
so they can have monomials that are a
function of
k samples simultaneously right so that
gives some additional power
and let me just give you an example
where this means that
polynomials perform better than
statistical queries
so one such example is if your null
distribution is uh
equations uh over
uh f p to the
n and your alternate distributions are
equations over the same space
but uh with planted solutions
so uh if i allow a degree
uh n n polynomial
then it can solve this problem with
gaussian elimination
uh n is pretty large but uh but you
realize that there's no dependence on p
okay whereas it's it's not too hard to
show that uh you need
p to the n uh queries
to uh v stat algorithm
um and if i send p to infinity faster
than n
then uh my my low degree polynomials are
beating
uh my statistical theory algorithms okay
so there's some kind of a
mismatch between these two models but
basically what we're able to show is
that if you rule out
these uh these uh two settings like
when neither of these issues arises the
models are equivalent so
when these donorize these don't happen
we get an equivalence
okay now this is the point where i'm
going to address chris's question which
is wait a minute like uh planet is my
favorite problem but you just told me
that statistical queries don't make
sense for planet clique so
like what's up with that um
well uh
what we can do is we we can do the
following so our issue is that
if a single sample is enough to
information theoretically distinguish
then statistical query algorithms can
essentially
uh you know like evaluate the likelihood
ratio on that one sample
and apply some thresholding to it and
then based on that it can can
automatically distinguish but many of
the problems that we care about are one
sample problems like for example the
planetary problem
so the answer
is to dilute the
uh halt distribution
uh so that the likelihood ratio
for one sample
is uh order one right so
um i'll say a little bit more about that
a little bit later
uh but but for planet clique one thing
that you can do is
okay so so and and the answer for how to
do this uh
comes actually from the reductions
literature
so it turns out that if you look at
planet clique
the following two formulations of the
problem are equivalent
under polynomial time reductions if you
look at uh
g and p
uh this is equivalent to m samples
from uh g and
p to the one over m
okay meaning that uh if i get a sample
from this distribution i can produce m
samples from this distribution and if i
get m samples from this distribution i
can produce a sample from this
distribution so
so the way to see that that happens is
you just get the m samples and then you
just
take the and function in every edge of
the graph that you saw
so that direction is kind of easy sorry
yeah yeah one question but
yeah i understand more or less it have
it but if you go this way then you rule
out for planted clique
pretty i don't know as kind of strange
class of algorithms right
are the algorithms that are statistical
query after you do this reduction
that's right so this reduction is not a
statistical query reduction
right so the algorithm that you can say
do not work
are these kind of strange algorithms
are some a class of algorithm that you
obtain after reduction from statistical
query
that's right i mean it's true i think
that there's no way to because because
statistical query algorithms can solve
the
uh plaintiff leak problem uh you know
there's nothing that we can really
there's nothing we can do about that but
the question is you know if you want
statistical queries
to be a valid proxy for polynomial time
algorithms if you want query complexity
to be a valid
proxy for polynomial algorithms what
condition should you meet
right so i'm saying well you know at
minimum we should should meet this
condition that the likelihood ratio for
a single sample is ordered i understand
i understand
where you come from right okay so
cool uh
great so uh yeah so so for planet clique
you do something like this
for gaussian problems it's also easy to
do the same thing so for example you
would replace a tensor pca
uh where your samples come from
a spike with
uh with strength lambda
these are equivalent to m samples
from uh spike with strength
lambda over root m again the reduction
here is is pretty easy you just
would take an average of all of your
samples
okay so this is a way of sort of tying
the statistical query oracle's
hands a little bit so that it can't uh
you know cheat and do things that
polynomial time algorithms cannot do oh
i see that i'm
essentially at the end of my talk time
i'm really sorry about that
um so
well okay this is a little bit
unfortunate i i guess i can do one of
two things i can sort of
sprint through definitions really fast
and show you the theorem statement
or i can try to conclude now what should
what does the audience want me to do
uh just go ahead just go ahead okay
all right so so what we're going to do
is we're going to
uh show that two notions of lower bounds
for these problems are
imply one another so uh for statistical
queries there's a
statistical there's this notion of
statistical dimension
um which uh which i will
define in a moment but the important
thing to know is that
if the statistical dimension at
tolerance m
scam is bigger than q then a statistical
query algorithm needs at least
q queries to v-stat order n
okay this is proved by feldman at all in
2013.
so even if you don't digest the
definition of sda
this is the thing that's important on
this slide here's the definition of sda
okay so uh yeah i don't really have
enough time to say what this was i was
hoping to give you all intuition for
what it means these are these are the
likelihood ratios
l u is like the likelihood ratio
with respect to the null distribution
but anyway it's it's trying to
measure on what subset of the
uh support like on what measure of the
support
of the um alternate distributions are
the the distributions likelihood ratios
correlated
all right so okay so whatever that means
i guess we won't i guess we won't digest
what fca means we just know that if the
sda is large then
uh statistical algorithms means a lot of
queries
okay and uh same thing with a low degree
likelihood ratio so
here i have an m sample version of the
of the likelihood ratio norm uh and uh
you know it's defined again uh
in terms of some uh
some projection of the m sample
likelihood ratios
okay and and yesterday alex uh really
nicely proved in his talk that
if the m sample likelihood ratio is
bounded then
uh degree d k polynomial tests can't
solve the hypothesis testing problem
okay so so when this quantity is small
uh we can't
solve the testing problem
okay and and our main theorem is
essentially as follows
um if the okay it just says that uh
if the likelihood ratio the low degree
likelihood ratio is small
then either the statistical dimension is
is large
appropriately large or there's a high
degree
k-sample test um so
if you want to plug in some parameters
here uh we're
saying that uh the like uh polylog
uh n uh ldlr
uh m order one
implies that uh sda
go tilde m is uh
n to the omega one so in the poly
logarithmic degree regime these models
are approximately equivalent unless
there's a k
sample test of high degree which is
what we kind of take as a proxy for um
the fact that with very few samples
a statistical query algorithm can
distinguish these by by running a brute
force uh
query and uh we also get a
converse statement that's essentially
the same
so i'm just going to flash it here
without going into details
okay and and let me just mention that
for both independent
for problems with independent
coordinates so let's say that uh
d0 and d uh u
are uh like product measures
over uh plus minus one to the n
then we rule out these like uh
these unless conditions right so we can
show that
if there's no low degree test then
there's no high degree test for a few
samples
uh and the same thing for a noise or
best problems
okay so so for these classical problems
we get more fine statements
um i don't have time to tell you the
proof idea but then what that lets us do
is it lets us
take a bunch of uh existing lower bounds
against either statistical queries or
low degree polynomials and get from them
uh with essentially no additional work
lower bounds for the other settings so
we get a lower bound
the first lower bound for statistical
algorithms from sparse pca by going via
low degree polynomials
and the same thing for gaussian mixtures
and
robust mean estimation going through sq
um okay
all right so i guess i'll close with a
with a
challenge a call to action uh let's
let's connect this graph
let's uh find more reductions between
algorithms
uh so that we can be like iceland air
uh the end thank you
uh great thanks snail uh questions for
it's neil
perhaps you've i answered all the
questions
i i i have a question so
spectral algorithms are also message
passing algorithms with a kind of
uh like linear update in the matrix
you're powering up right
so i guess there's sort of a trivial
arrow in one direction there
yeah there's i guess there's sort of i
mean it all depends on if you uh
how you defend or sorry how how you
define spectral algorithm
uh so yeah i mean i think that in a lot
of the cases when you're connecting the
graph and this was certainly true in in
this
in this project um it was very important
to define things properly
we flailed around for a long time trying
to define things
properly but then once we did things
didn't things weren't so bad
um so you want kind of uh
like when you're drawing these arrows
you want to draw an arrow
in a way that's sort of like
sufficiently
broad to capture a lot of things but not
too restrictive
yeah i mean a a remark on that is that a
major challenge i think is going to be
you know giving
getting definitions for each of these
boxes that
enable you to use the same definition
for multiple arrows
right so there's still already alluded
to the fact that like
the definition of spectral algorithms
that one uses for this spectral versus
sos thing
is kind of the wrong definition in some
sense because it doesn't permit you it's
not the same definition as you should
use to translate between spectral
algorithms and low degree polynomials
and this is some very annoying um you
know technical failure of these uh of
these theorems that they can't be
composed
so somehow uh
yeah it's it's never it's never exactly
what the right definitions are and this
is
still yeah a mystery
so i mean just the clarification because
i couldn't see the statements very well
and
since we talked a little bit earlier
about some exponential time algorithms
like do you get also this
kind of correspondence yeah so right so
in the sub exponential
okay uh in the sub-exponential regime
the issue is that you okay so there's
this factor of k here in the denominator
so so the statement says that
uh slightly i mean depending on where in
the sub-exponential regime you are
a slightly less powerful uh statistical
query
oracle is equivalent to the low degree
um so so like for example for tensor pca
we are able to get
a sub-exponential time lower bound for
statistical query algorithms
from the low-degree lower bounds but
but there's like a it's slightly
sub-optimal in the in the exponent
that's all i thought we are losing like
constant factors in the second exponent
like if
like two to the n to the epsilon becomes
maybe two to the n to the epsilon over
two
something something of that kind of
flavor yeah two to that
two to the ends epsilon is like two to
the n to the maybe like one minus delta
times epsilon where delta
you know worsens as you increase epsilon
yeah
all right so there's some loss there's
some loss that works in this exponential
regime but with
some kind of painful losses yeah in the
in the paper maybe um like the statement
for tense or pca
is illustrative of the kind of loss yeah
there's a question from alex does he
want to say it out loud
oh sure i mean i was just wondering
whether sq
actually predicts the right sub
exponential runtime for
any problems that we know of or like
what is yeah so
so it's my it's my recollection that if
you try to
directly bound the um
statistical query like if you directly
bound the sda for tensorbca
not using the low-degree
result then you do get the correct
sub-exponential trade-off
um i think okay yeah
but i'm not confident in that i have to
check again yeah sorry
so does this theorem give like the end
to the k over two threshold for like
random kx or set
going back and forth yeah so that's
another so that's another good point so
it does but but v stat
is a lower bound for uh
statistical queries and in particular
it's not necessarily the case that it's
a
sharp characterization of this sq
complexity so
um it may be the case that
the statistical dimension is small
but in fact there are no matching uh
statistical query algorithms i see
i mean when we wrote that paper we had
to define a different dimension yeah
statistical dimension to get an
algorithm and they got a matching bound
and we had like vectors
right you had this like uh yeah
yeah we we had thought about trying to
generalize this to
you know understand the relationship
with themselves we didn't look into it
very
thoroughly yet i think that's a great um
question
any more questions for its leo
[Music]
yeah let's thank her one more time
in the sound
uh friends i think it's more or less
come to an end
uh except that um
there's one more social hour we shall go
to it's friday i mean come on it's an
hour and a half i put the um link to it
up there
in the chat uh we should see you there i
think peter bartlett said he would
reimburse all your drinks so
come prepared send them your receipts
and
um yeah let's hang out for a bit there
uh at 5 pm eastern 2 p.m pacific
i'll see you there see you see y'all
there i
i really appreciate all the fantastic
talks this week
including the last few so thank you all
very much
yeah thank you guys thank you very much
[Music]
yeah thanks ryan thanks chris that was
great yeah
see you all soon